Marine Le Pen quelle question vous lui
poseriez
où Pétain ou Poutine
alors merci Jordan d'être là merci à
vous bon allez vous en avez pris plein
la gueule à tout le weekend tout le
monde vous a défoncé
de méthode parce que bonsoir d'abord
parce que en fait ça fait 30 ans qu'ils
font ça et plus nous attaque plus on
monte en fait à chaque fois qu'on est la
vérité dans les sondages parce que c'est
bon
soirée pour c'était une soirée c'était
pourquoi déjà ah oui c'est une soirée
pour une chaîne je sais pas quoi je l'ai
vu c'est la première fois que je le
croisais vous invitez beaucoup de gens
du rassemblement national j'ai écouté
nous on invite tout le monde ici tout le
monde a le droit à la parole toute la
parole toutes les paroles des Français
sont les bienvenus sur notre plateau et
il me dit oui mais il vaut mieux ne pas
les inviter je dis ben oui ben vous
allez vous parler beaucoup d'eux mais
visiblement dans les sondages ils
montent toujours plus que quand vous
n'en parlez pas donc nous on préfère
faire parler les gens voir si on est
d'accord avec eux ou pas selon leurs
idées voilà Jordan je l'invite souvent
on sait qu'on est on n'est pas on n'est
pas d'accord sur plein de trucs c'est
vrai mais on fait non mais bien sûr mais
en fait c'est la démocratie c'est-à-dire
à un moment donné on est en désaccord
avec nous on nous combat sur nos idées
et moi j'ai envie de dire à Monsieur
Dupont moitié venez débattre vous savez
moi on devait débattre ensemble sur BFM
TV il a annulé le débat voilà il avait
accepté le débat finalement il a annulé
donc moi j'ai envie de lui dire venez
nous combattre sur nos études il faut
qu'elle se rende compte fixation sur
vous
répulsion
il y a quelques années il avait dit il
faut interdire le Front national il
était interrogé sur France Inter sur le
service public et il a dit il faut
interdire le Front national ben ce que
je lui répond c'est que c'est le
meilleur moyen de nous faire monter ce
que je réponds c'est qu'il est ministre
de la République française quoi et que
quand on est ministre de la République
française on peut pas insulter des
millions de Français en permanence
c'est-à-dire que on a le sentiment que
il passe leur temps à jeter les Français
les uns contre les autres c'est-à-dire
que il y a une réforme en personne ne
veut il laisse les Français s'opposer
dans la rue il y a un parti politique
qui monte plutôt que de répondre à ces
idées il préfère insulter de péter Nice
d'extrême droite alors justement
beaucoup de gens je vais vous dire parce
que quand il nous insultes en fait moi
je m'en fous j'ai le cuir solide et
Marine Le Pen encore plus elle dit quoi
Marine Le Pen euh s'intéresse pas
beaucoup à Dupont-Moretti mais mais mais
quand il nous insulte en fait ils
insultent des millions de gens ils
insultent des millions de Français et
quand on leur répond on a le sentiment
de défendre des millions de gens qui ne
se sentent pas d'extrême droite qui ne
se sentent pas poutinistes qui ne se
sentent pas pété Nice qui se sentent
simplement français et fier de l'est pas
d'extrêmement et pour qui estimez pas
d'extrême droite non d'accord vous êtes
de quel bord politique je me sens
patriote mais en quoi je serai d'extrême
droite
alors Jordan tu vois non mais peut-être
allez-y je vous en prie non mais
justement enfin c'est l'historique d'un
parti en quoi je serai d'extrême droite
vous oui
rassemblement national
sur quelle mesure sur quelle vision tout
un parcours d'un parti politique lequel
sur des allées bah je vais pas vous
refaire le parcours national
c'est vrai que il se rapproche des idées
de Pétain le front le rassemblement
national attendez juste fin regardez je
vous montre
le Front national
n'a pas fait comment dire l'autocritique
le travail nécessaire sur ses racines
justement sur son en revanche a quand
même et puis parfois dans son programme
il y a une ou deux choses qui rappelle
la priorité nationale le droit du sang
tout ça c'est quand même assez ça
rappelle bien cette époque en revanche
elle a fait une rupture aussi elle a
aussi
exclus son père elle a aussi voulu
elle a un discours contre
l'antisémitisme qu'elle revendique donc
il faut faire une balance dans cela
c'est long c'est long c'est long alors
si vous répondez à ça écoutez le front
le rassemblement national n'est pas le
Front national voilà c'est pour ça non
mais c'est qu'on s'est présenté à toutes
les élections depuis des années à la
création vous savez du Front national en
1972 il y a beaucoup de résistants aussi
et il y avait notamment monsieur Bidault
Georges Bideau qui a été le successeur
de Jean Moulin qui a été le président du
Conseil National de la Résistance or ça
ça n'est jamais abordé mais si oui
j'aimerais bien moi je suis né en 19 95
donc je me sens pas de lien avec Pétain
et pour moi la France en 1940 elle était
avec le général de Gaulle à Londres donc
j'aimerais bien qu'on me dise
aujourd'hui tu voulais encore des craint
est-ce que non mais est-ce que de de
d'être critique vis-à-vis de la
politique d'immigration on a le droit de
l'être ou je veux dire on est forcément
catalogué comme d'extrême droite est-ce
que de vouloir utiliser le référendum
utiliser la proportionnelle aux
élections pour rendre le pouvoir au
peuple c'est d'extrême droite je ne le
crois pas est-ce que mais c'est
intéressant parce que il faut nous dire
donc moi je me laisserai pas
sur vos côtes en ce moment vous pouvez
passer les sondages
[Musique]
alors regardez parce que un peu plus tôt
dans l'émission il avait déjà mis un
gros tac la Marine Le Pen il citer tous
les éléments qui selon lui la discrédité
pour signer pourquoi il veut pas
débattre monsieur Dupont il est bien sur
quelle époque il est content mon
applaudit
non plus là il est au spectacle tout le
monde Laponie il fait mincir rideau
merci pas se faire chier non plus ce qui
vous disent justement les électeurs qui
vous disent on a essayé la gauche on a
essayé la droite rien à marcher et du
coup on va essayer Marine Le Pen vous
leur dites quoi je leur dis qu'elle nous
a elle a jamais essayé c'est vrai mais
elle est la courroie de transmission du
Kremlin pour l'avortement à la parler à
un moment d'avortement de confort elle
voulait sortir de l'euro puis rester
dans l'euro elle voulait être européenne
mais avec un nombre de pays restreints
etc etc là elle veut une perpétuité
réelle c'est un de ces mantras ça existe
déjà c'est d'ailleurs la peine a été à
laquelle a été condamnée Abdeslam Salah
il s'étouffe dans sa haine c'est-à-dire
qu'il est il est plein de plein de plein
de haine
et on sent qu'il nous aime pas mais ça
se souvient qu'il accepte la
confrontation et qui et surtout quand on
a un bilan comme ça franchement quand il
y a une agression gratuite toutes les 44
secondes en France normalement au lutte
contre l'insécurité quand on est
ministre de la justice quand on voit les
cas de harcèlement scolaire qui traverse
l'actualité quand on voit tous les jours
des gens qui sont remis en liberté alors
qu'ils ont commis des délits des crimes
des récidivistes normalement on s'occupe
e de ça on n'est pas en train si vous
voulez d'aller sur les plateaux de
télépoque vous invitez dans quelle
époque ils m'ont invité une fois
je pense que je n'entendrai pas vous en
défoncé
non mais on a un peu le sentiment qu'il
y a un traitement particulier qui nous
aide pour maurity ouais vous passez à la
séquence avec moi c'est un peu moins
sympa parce que là il est imposé qu'il y
a un truc et il dit je vais acheter du
pain tout le monde c'est génial
c'est une émission qui enregistré donc
quand vous avez des coupes au montage
c'est en fait ici il y a pas de coupe on
est en direct mais je sais dans sa je
reviens donc c'est bernardier la coté
il écoute pas les consignes du président
de la République en plus il y a quelques
jours c'est la première ministre c'est
Isabelle borde qui avait déjà fait un
lien entre Pétain et le rassemblement
national c'est de là que c'est parti
recadrer par le président
qui montre qu'il est de la poignée avec
la ministre mais bon voilà et donc bah
apparemment ça a pas marché parce que
Eric Dupond-Moretti et vous aime pas
vous aime pas
ce que ça vous empêche de dormir c'est
non ce qui m'empêche de dormir c'est son
c'est son bilan c'est la violence qui
compte qui vous aime pas j'ai voulu
inviter vous aime pas
du tout à la normalisation du
rassemblement national je pense qu'il
faut pas banaliser ses idées ses idées
sont toujours les mêmes alors maintenant
le rassemblement national il met les
formes je n'ai jamais entendu Marine Le
Pen dénonçait ce qu'on peut être les
positions historiques de son de son
parti et je pense que un changement de
non ne change pas les idées des racines
voilà alors
quelle partie madame borne partie
sociale le Parti socialiste a fait lire
en 80
est-ce que sa motorise pour autant à
dire que Madame borne et l'héritière du
Maréchal Pétain non donc si vous voulez
on peut pas comme ça dans la démocratie
française salir les gens insulter un
jurrier madame born dit les idées du RN
sont dangereuses mais quelles idées
pourquoi on va jamais sur le fond parce
que vous croyez que leurs idées à eux
sont pas dangereuses alors de faire
passer des textes de loi sans les faire
voter à l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas
dangereux de faire passer les textes de
loi que personne ne veut c'est pas
dangereux de prendre des mesures
toujours plus dures sur les libertés
publiques
va faire c'est pas ce que vous auriez
fait aussi voilà on sait pas c'est vrai
que après
donc c'est comme les mecs qui sont pas
l'antenne ici j'y vais à l'antenne je
réfléchis j'aurais fait ça moi combien y
en a des donneurs de leçons ils sont pas
l'antenne ils sont à notre alimentation
ils sont chez eux en train de manger des
chipsters alors non mais Jordan juste il
y a un autre extrait vous avez vu il y a
une histoire là on pourrait revenir sur
la polémique autour de Grégoire de
Fornas qu'il en a parlé en fait
Eric Dupond-Moretti en novembre dernier
il avait été accusé de propos racistes à
l'encontre d'un député à les filles
quand il avait lancé qu'il retourne en
Afrique alors voilà et donc et regardez
Eric Dupond-Moretti samedi soir il en a
remis une couche mais apparemment il a
pas eu les conclusions de il y a eu des
conclusions l'Assemblée nationale il
disparaît enfin je sais pas ce qu'il
fait d'ailleurs il fait quoi la journée
c'est du piment non mais c'est
intéressant de poser la question payer
par vos impôts à tous ils ministre de la
Justice la situation en matière de
violence se dégrade donc à moins quand
le type est pas bon le choc est devenu
champion de 1000 Bornes regardez le
rassemblement national je voudrais vous
redire des choses là là c'est de
l'actualité je repars pas 30 ans en
arrière avec les dur à four crématoires
et cetera et cetera et point de détails
de l'histoire il y a un député qui
s'adresse à un député de la France
insoumise qui est noire qui veut dire
tourne en Afrique c'était il y a 6 mois
voilà
vous avez raison il a pas lu les gens on
en avait parlé ensemble il y a 6 mois
qui parlait du parler du bateau c'était
pas faim
plutôt que de dire il y a pas eu de
conneries reconnaître qu'il y a une
connerie pourquoi parce que c'est
naturel à créer une confusion et que ça
nous a attiré plusieurs semaines de
polémique mais je veux dire qu'on était
dans un débat là on parlait d'un bateau
à l'assemblé enfin on va faire le mal
voilà
tu risques du plomberie sur ça vous lui
répondez quoi mais je vais pas lui
répondre si vous voulez je veux dire je
pense que il y a une enfin les gens qui
nous regardent aujourd'hui n'arrivent
plus à boucler les fins de mois
s'inquiète quand on leur fils ou leur
fille prend les transports en commun le
soir parce que la situation matière
d'insécurité explose dans les transports
en commun et notamment ici il y a des
mouvements sociaux ah bah quand on est
ministre de la Justice ouais un peu euh
il y a des mouvements sociaux tous les
quatre matins qui paralysent le pays
parce que les gens ont le sentiment de
pu être entendu et quand on a des
ministres qui disent notre objectif
c'est de taper sur le rassemblement
national mais je veux dire ils sont pas
ils sont pas élus pour ça pour les a pas
choisi pour il a été samedi soir dans
l'émission
vous l'avez regardez ou pas alors je
sais je suis pas son porte-paro non je
ne l'ai pas regardé
vous avez fait quoi samedi avec des amis
samedi soir
non les gens foot donc complètement ah
ouais ils sont vraiment à vous l'aviez
vu l'extrait ou le découvrir chez moi je
l'ai vu ce matin ah d'accord ouais je
l'ai vu ce matin et Marine Le Pen elle
vous en a parlé ou pas du tout mais
salut franchement elle est retouche
politique elle en a vu d'autres et des
un peu plus un peu plus tenace donc
elles sont fous un peu plus épais que
Monsieur Dupond-Moretti donc elle s'en
fout complètement vous en foutez là que
tout le monde se soit sur vos côtes en
ce moment je pour moi c'est bon signe ah
ouais ouais parce que quand vous êtes
finalement désigné comme des adversaires
par ces gens là c'est que vous êtes
probablement pas si mauvais que ça
premièrement et que deuxièmement si
décide de faire du rassemblement
national et pas de la nupaise d'ailleurs
par exemple une cible c'est parce qu'ils
savent qu'on représente une menace non
pas pour les Français mais pour eux en
fait pour leur poste et qui savent que
en fait on peut arriver au pouvoir mais
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai envie de leur
dire si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
mes idées venez me dire pourquoi mes qui
sont pas mal et je vous dirai pourquoi
les vôtres sont catastrophiques mais
mais arrêtez d'insulter les gens parce
que ça fait 30 ans qu'ils font ça et
continuer moi je ils peuvent nous
énerve quand on vous dit que vous êtes
en partie d'extrême droite c'est quoi un
parti d'extrême droite aujourd'hui donc
il y en a plus en France si c'est
minoritaire quelques groupes qui qui
prône la violence je pense que l'extrême
droite dans l'histoire ça correspond à
une définition bien précise l'extrême
droite c'est le rejet du parlementarisme
c'est l'éloge de la discrimination c'est
l'éloge de la violence c'est le refus du
débat démocratique parce que on ne
correspond en rien à tout cela avant
avant c'est ce qu'on avait dans la tête
donc c'est pas ce que vous vous avez
changé de nom c'est comme si on le
prenait des granola mais c'est pareil
non je crois pas
d'extrême droite la notion de grand
rempli
elle est d'extrême droite
parce que je pense qu'il est il est
parce que je pense que les gens
comprennent pas mais je veux dire que
dans des quartiers aujourd'hui entier
notamment dans mon département
Seine-Saint-Denis où elle est à la gare
du Nord euh les gens ont le sentiment de
ne plus reconnaître le pays dans lequel
ils ont grandi c'est une réalité et je
vous mets au défi de me dire que quand
vous êtes à la gare du Nord vous vous
sentez en sécurité est-ce que vous allez
vous balader Jordan
évidemment
Bourger vous prenez votre jet vous
passez par là vous passez-le
d'Aubervilliers par la porte de la
Chapelle les gens qui vont en hélico
les gens qui votent pour vous ils
passent pas par là les gens qui votent
pour vous ils sont plus dans les
campagnes pas du tout dis pas de bêtises
non là tu dis des bêtises à Paris le
frontale le rassemblement national fait
pas des scores extraordinaires
est-ce que vous diriez Eric
Dupond-Moretti comme ça on clôt le débat
parce qu'il lui dit des bâtons des
bâtons
à retrouver un peu de courage BFM TV
nous avait fait une proposition de débat
donc peut-être qu'on pourra débattre de
fond mais là c'est compliqué parce qu'il
va se retrouver coincé pendant 2h30 où
il va devoir justifier son bilan et son
bilan c'est qu'il y a un Français toutes
les 44 secondes qui est victime d'une
agression